the idea that Ukraine is actually going
to realistically throw Putin out of its
territory entirely is now I think pretty
much off the cards several of the senior
people that I spoke to zinsky people
that I spoke to in Kev over the last
couple of weeks believe still that
they'll be able to do for better in a
spring offensive but frankly I'm not
sure how that's going to happen because
they don't have air superiority even if
they do get f16s they're not really
going to achieve the same the the kind
of overwhelming a superiority that they
need for a massive breakthrough and
they're basically going to be in the
same situation as they are now which is
fighting through a very deep and
comprehensively defended barrier of
trenches and minefields and so on